all right we are now live and I've got
my mic sitting over here next to me
hopefully that'll work a little bit
better than they have in the past I'm up
in our library slash bedroom it's not
particularly well lit because we don't
have an overhead light but let's see if
we can get the lighting a little bit
better there we go so it's Valentine's
Day and I you know we aren't doing much
for us because it's super cold outside
today but we're gonna have some sushi a
little bit later and and relax and enjoy
ourselves and then probably work quite
frankly but I was thinking about
something that was kind of interesting
about Valentine's Day and old memory and
let me actually address Kostis what is
the purpose of this livestream exactly
what it says in the description it's an
impromptu livestream I do these sort of
things as philosophy pop ups quite quite
frequently people ask questions and make
comments and I respond to them and
that's that's the the shtick
right that's how we we do things but you
know I got my first metal album on a
Valentine's Day a long time ago and it
was kiss destroyer we were really into
kiss on my block and I I hung out with
the older boys you know and some of them
and I'd like kiss alive or or love God
and stuff like that and so my mom knew
that my mom knew how into kiss we were
because I was like constantly talking
about Ace Frehley the spaceman and we
would draw with our crayons you know the
different kiss kiss people and I was
always into a Sri Li and so she she got
I don't remember what she got from my
sister but she got me the kiss destroyer
album and she was like happy Valentine's
Day and it was totally out of the blue
because we'd never done Valentine's Day
presents before and I don't think we
ever did them again
and so you know it was it was kind of an
interesting thing
you know I had other metal things before
I like really got into metal before we
sort of identified it as such like I had
Def Leppard's pyromania on tape but you
know and I'll tell the story some other
time or if we we reach a law in this at
some point about how I got more into it
around the age of 13 or so through a
buddy of mine recording an Iron Maiden
song on a cassette tape that he put Van
Halen's 1984 on and there was a little
bit of room so he put Iron Maiden's the
trooper and that really got me going
with metal and then it's you know it's
been the rest of my life all right let
me let me start taking some of these
questions a lot of people saying hello
then let's that's very nice happy
Valentine's Day to different people dan
the man has a practical question I'm
about to give a presentation of my
senior thesis to Mississippi Academy of
Science do I have any tips for giving
presentations I'm very very nervous
that's actually a really good question
and I'm gonna move the mic a little bit
so it's not
things aren't bobbling around so much
yeah you know I do have some bits of
advice that might be helpful but first
congratulations that on getting your
senior thesis done that's really
excellent and I'm imagining you know
like my senior thesis I just presented
it to you know panel three professors
but the academy of science that sounds
like kind of a big deal so that's that's
really cool I mean I would I would say
you know practice your presentation a
couple times before and do it with do
like one run-through with your friends
and just tell them to like you know the
first run-through because they already
know you're nervous don't have them give
any tips or critique or anything just
tell them to sit down and shut up and
and watch you and just run through it
like you would the whole thing and then
maybe you know on another day have them
give you some some tips another thing
that I will say
you see a lot with first-time presenters
or early career presenters is talking
really fast talking talking too fast for
the audience so it may sound a little
silly to you but I would say you know
deliberately slow yourself down and you
may be able to eyes appends on how
self-aware you are and and you know when
you're when you're presenting you can go
from being a very self-aware person to
being a less self-aware person but I
would say you know if you can try to you
know try to like slow your diction down
and don't worry about getting everything
in and you know it'll it'll help you
your thoughts will I think become more
clear as you're going on I know there's
a tendency to speed things up but but
that's pretty important not to and maybe
you have somebody else in the audience
as well like if you start talking really
fast they can like give you a hand
signal or something and you know the
other thing I would say is if you if you
miss miss state something you can always
back it up and say oh you know I I think
I misstated something let me you know
clarify this because nobody's expecting
you to do a polished you know TED Talks
sort of performance right I am I'm
assuming so maybe that would that would
help you a bit alright let's see what
else we get here hard geese vanmeer bowl
maybe any current day music you're into
you know some contemporary metal stuff
you know when with older bands make new
stuff like Judas Priest has firepower
that came up we saw that tour you know I
listen to it and Saxon has a new album
that's not too old and you know there's
their stuff like that and then there's
there's some newer bands
in the genre music I like doom metal so
like orchid you would consider newer but
I don't think they put anything out for
for quite a while so yeah there's some
some stuff I'm done you know there's
bands that my kids or my wife like that
I have come to appreciate you know like
you know I enjoy it's a good thing I do
because they listen to it constantly
when they're here
I enjoy Liz oh I've come to enjoy some
imagine dragons you know because my kids
are into that as well so you know
there's there's that let's say William
asks any advice for studying natural
theology for self-directed learners
thank you again so natural theology
we're talking about you know what's
often called philosophy of religion it's
making arguments and going into
exposition and and trying to you know
get to the bottom of what is what is
this thing that we call God and you know
God's relations with the rest of the
universe by means of primarily reason
and experience rather than relying
directly on revealed theology right so
are there any are there any tips it
depends on you know who you're looking
at I I guess I would say that important
in anything with religion is to you know
bracket your own your own beliefs and
figure out what people are actually
claiming and saying that's that's quite
important and you know I always say play
supremacy on understanding first and
then on agreement and then on
appreciation you you want to make sure
that you thoroughly understand where a
thinker is coming from and the the other
thing I would say too is the dividing
line between philosophy on one side and
and theology or faith or you know
religion on the other side
that is a shifting border and it's it's
you know to define where the border lies
is a philosophical or theological act
and there's always presuppositions so
there's no perfectly neutral way to go
about it there's always assumptions
being made so I would try to be like you
know cognizance of that all right
Leonardo asks how do I create discipline
do I have any tips I don't have any tips
but I do have a sort of quip and that's
you create discipline bit by bit by you
know behaving in a disciplined way
failing and then picking yourself up and
then you know being a little bit more
disciplined so you know usually when
we're asking about like how to create a
new habit it's because it's it's not
there and we'd like it to be there and
we're doing something else that we
probably shouldn't be doing instead
right so how do you how do you change
your your habits how do you change your
ways of approaching things how do you
change your assumptions that you're
making and your your emotional you know
responses and sort of knee-jerk
reactions a lot of that it requires
being attentive to what's going on so
you know one thing that could be helpful
is journaling or even I you know when
I'm when I'm working with clients and
doing workshops I often like have
worksheets that aren't even quite at the
level of journaling but like let's say
it's anger management right
it's got like a tracker for each day and
like did I lose my temper what did I
lose my temper over what was going
through my head at the time so like
keeping track of those sorts of things
and gradually you you come to understand
your motivations and what's what's
happening with you right so I would say
that that might be helpful but the other
thing is don't get too discouraged when
you fail because when you're trying to
do something new trying to create a new
path for yourself the reason you're
going to fail and you're going to fail a
lot at the start because it's a new path
for yourself
so you don't want to get yourself caught
in this this cycle where like you you
you set these super high goals for
yourself and of course you fail at it
and then you feel crappy and then you're
like oh I got to find some way to
compensate for this so you deny that you
you failed or you minimize how you
failed it's better to say oh man this
this is crap I really screwed up I guess
I'm starting over at day one sort of
like those things where it shows like
you know so we've gotten this many days
without without an accident or an injury
and the plant well when it happens you
go back to zero but you're not if you're
if you're working at it you're not
really going back to zero because you
have made a little bit of progress and
it starts to get easier and you can I
guess that would be a third thing you
could remind yourself that when you
start feeling down about not being
disciplined you can remind yourself that
you have made some progress provided you
have made some progress so alright
here's a question about play-doh from
Toby
after having seriously read the timaeus
the Meno in the Phaedo I must ask you to
what extent do you think Plato believes
in the doctrine of reincarnation that's
a good question so there's there's
there's really kind of two ways to go
with that one would be to say oh you
know this is just kind of symbolic and
it's not really Plato's own view he's
doing something else there but then you
got explained what exactly he's doing
and I've never found a really
satisfactory explanation for that or you
say okay he is serious about this notion
of reincarnation
how do we how do we reconcile these
accounts because there's also one - in
in the Republic right in the book ten so
Meno fado there's also the Phaedrus does
it come up in any other places I'd have
to think about that it's been a while
since I've thought about this this
particular topic but you know one of the
challenges is of explaining exactly
what's supposed to be going
there because Plato says these are these
are myths right this is not a rational
exposition in dialectic the way
something else might be you know another
thing you can do too is you can look at
middle and neoplatonist accounts where
they try to harmonize this stuff that
might be might be helpful as well but I
personally I think that Plato is serious
about reincarnation let's see here
Marcellus what here's a politics
question do you think a bit what do I
think about the u.s. foreign policy and
destroying secular Arab states in favor
of Muslim Brotherhood and even terrorist
groups which isn't in the interest of
anyone including US citizens well yeah
when you put it like that that sounds
like a bad idea right if you're if
you're talking about like the Gulf War
too you know the dismantling of the
Saddam Hussein regime and the Baathist
States I I think that you know and I
actually was was for getting rid of
Hussein but I didn't want to see a power
vacuum afterwards seem like we're quite
good at taking things down because we've
got this you know immense military power
that we can extend all over the place
and then we're terrible at actually
putting things back together in any
reasonable way that takes account of
what's going on in in the place and how
to build you know lasting coalition's
that would be stable and and so you know
we did a terrible job at reconstruction
and we're still paying the price you
know almost two decades later and we
probably will be for decades yet to come
so I don't I don't think that that
keeping you know if you're talking about
totalitarian secular Arab States I don't
think that's a great thing to have there
Hussein was was was horrible to his
people I actually had a cousin who was
in force recon and I was corresponding
with him and he was one of the first
people to go into Iran
and we were corresponding about Just War
theory and what was going on and he was
telling me about some of the stuff that
that you know was being reported to him
by locals that they had gone through
just in recent years and how happy they
were to be essentially liberated and so
you know there's something to that but
then you don't want things just to
degenerate into it doesn't have to be
Muslim Muslim Brotherhood there's all
sorts of other things that could be
equally problematic as well and so we
have to we have to do more than just
break things and and you know say
mission accomplished we we actually have
to do real reconstruction if we're going
to be involved in any of these sorts of
things still trying to get the lighting
a little bit better there you don't want
the light on the screen because it's
it's so strong but yeah so there that
that that's my take on on that William
has another question any suggestions for
someone giving their first lecture as a
teacher I feel I will bore my students
okay well yeah so I do in fact have a
few things to say one is I would say I'm
not sure why you would necessarily bore
your students but pick something that
you you think is intrinsically
interesting and that probably has a good
you know the it's there's enough there
that they can get into and it's readable
enough for them to get into it maybe you
don't have much control over your
curriculum though and and so you're kind
of stuck on whatever it is that you've
got to teach then you have less
flexibility right but you know you can
you know you could you can do some
things ahead of time that might help you
maybe see if you can come up with some
interesting examples and and you know
have them in either in your notes or you
could create a handout for your students
that's a great way to get get ideas
across somebody who I'm a big fan of and
I think a lot of people know I'm a big
fan of st. Anselm of Canterbury that's
one major way that he taught was by
using what he we call similitudes or
likenesses and said well you know the
this is like this and so let's unpack
that analogies would be another way of
talking about it and you know be I would
say also be ready for weird oddball
questions to come up and and you can
sort of be open and say well you know
this isn't exactly what we're talking
about but let's see if we can feel this
and I think you'll probably do okay of
course I don't I don't know you saw
right yeah
all right Marcellus Tacitus what is your
take on Islam that's you know that's a
really broad question that's like saying
what do you think about Buddhism or what
do you think about Hinduism all sorts of
things it's one of the major world
religions and you know which which sort
of version or interpretation of it are
we talking about you know there's
there's a lot of that would have to be
unpacked there so all right Quentin says
taking a break from half hour Hegel to
check this out it's very nice glad
you're enjoying that I'm Quentin also
says firepower's priest best album in
like 25 years so how far back with that
that go 25 years we're in 2020 absorbed
in 1995 you know I probably go along
with that because my favorite albums are
basically up to defenders of the faith I
thought turbo there's some good songs on
there but I didn't really like the
departure into so much synth and Ram it
down was good you know in some respects
and not so great in other respects I
really think that that priests best
album is in my view sin after sin and
and I would probably say screaming for
vengeance firepower's fun seeing Judas
Priest slide is a lot of fun we have
seen them four times in the last 10
years
my wife and I two times out east and two
times here in Milwaukee so we've seen
them with Thin Lizzy who old Steel
Panther uriah heep saxon and black star
riders so that's you know that's pretty
good all right
giorgio asks do I think Aristotle was an
atheist would he have appreciated
medieval Christianity with its logos
more than the paganism of his own time I
don't think Aristotle was an atheist he
certainly seems to think that there's
something going on in the super lunar
airy realm it's not quite clear what
what is exactly going on and I'm not a
specialist on you know on the heavens or
things like that but he does he
definitely talks about Theo so he's not
an atheist and he seems to think that
there's there's something happening with
like the planets and the stars and all
that and and it's kind of interesting
stuff would he have appreciated medieval
Christianity more than the paganism of
his own time depends on sort of like the
Islam question whose medieval
Christianity because we're like all over
the map if he ran into say Peter Damian
and he'd be like oh I don't need these
people you know Peter Damien said that
not only its philosophy but grammar was
a tool of the devil right so you know
that's you're not gonna have much trash
with somebody like Aristotle if the
Aristotle had been able to hang out with
boethius who was translating Aristotle
by the way or you know II Regina or
Alcoa nor you know Ansem or Eloise or
Abelard or you know let alone Thomas
Aquinas I think he he probably would
have enjoyed chatting with them it's
kind of an interesting hypothetical to
think about isn't it
so yeah I mean the paganism of his time
was never a coherent system and you know
we often portrayed as well either the
twelve gods and stuff like that no I was
just a mishmash of all these different
cults and then you got Homer and Hesiod
and the tragedy and is mixed up with it
and so it was kind of a mess really but
yeah it's a good it's a good question
all right um let's see what else do we
we have skipped a little bit so John
asked me my valentine back to say oh
well I'm uh I'm already you know my
wife's Valentine so I can't do that
Jake McCully what publications would you
recommend to a layperson hoping to keep
up with the academic philosophical
community you mean like what websites or
what journals I I don't know I mean that
I don't think that's answerable because
there's just like so much stuff getting
churned out I don't think anyone can
keep up with the the current academic
community in a way we live in a really
great time because we have so much
access to stuff and then we also live in
a terrible time because we have so much
access to stuff it's it's it's
impossible to stay on top of more than
just a small area in in philosophy
unfortunately so I I don't have any good
good suggestions on that Colin asks any
thoughts generally on Peter
slaughter Dick's work specifically as
ideas of general acid ology and Co
immune ISM from you must change your
life
I haven't read him so I can't can't
comment I know I can say this his fans
are really into him you know and I've
been recommended to check him out but I
just haven't gotten around to it I'm
usually at at any given point in time a
little bit behind in my own reading and
commitments to get things read so
I'm looking over there at the books that
are stacked up that I'm supposed to have
reviewed in videos months ago all right
here's one from geez
Liz dough is actually really good for a
pop artist good on you for being
open-minded yeah I really like her stuff
I mean I I do like quite a lot of other
music other than just metal you know
there's there's bands and artists who I
really enjoy from all sorts of eras and
and her stuff is really well put
together I enjoy it and I like you know
that it's it's also kind of free and
raunchy and fun and and yeah I mean I'm
not I'm not big into pop or R&B or stuff
like that but there's you know people
might be surprised about the kind of
things that I actually do like kind of
bands that I like all right this is from
Adrian could you give some suggestions
for films that explore philosophical
themes especially me ilysm and dealing
with meaninglessness what are my
favorites well that changes the game
when you ask about me ilysm because I
was gonna say yeah I mean like you know
people always bring up the matrix but I
actually prefer dark City for that and I
used to show in my classes I would show
memento as well right which deals with
memory I mean there's a lot of really
good good films out there from a
philosophical perspective I would say
anything that's you know originally
based on a philip k dick book is a short
story it's usually a great starting
point and my my absolute favorite when
it comes to that both in in the books
and and the movies is a Scanner Darkly
which is about it's about drugs and you
know the nature of reality and there's
sort of kind of cops and and dissidents
stories mixed in there and there's a lot
of like think
to the ends justify the means dick
himself although he took a lot of drugs
was also in some respects anti-drug
because he thought that it had really
destroyed an entire generation you know
this is a sort of easy hedonistic
lifestyle but Neel ISM okay so I mean
jokingly we could say the big lebowski
of course right because there's neo
lists in there but they don't really
play much of a role and I don't know
that that the movie itself is really
that nihilistic I will say though that
that you know as another thing you could
say is as a Coen Brothers movie some of
those can be quite nihilistic especially
you think about their first one Blood
Simple which is a neo noir that's that's
kind of a good one for that you know
another movie that I thought I was I saw
in the theaters and I I actually thought
it was really quite funny at the end the
Ninth Gate Johnny Depp it's like an
occultist kind of movie he's searching
after this thing to like open up the
these nine gates and you know experience
transcendence the people in the theater
were pissed when that movie ended
because and I won't actually tell you
how it ends I'll just say the ending
makes perfect sense but a lot of viewers
watch it and are enraged at how it ends
is it nihilistic not exactly but it kind
of kind of deals with that you know
another thing that I would say is kind
of interesting as well dealing with the
problem of meaninglessness and I forget
the name of this Polish filmmaker he's
the guy who did the tricolor thing after
the iron curtain came down you know red
blue white prior to that he did a set of
short essentially I think they were TV
episodes called the Ten Commandments and
you might say oh that sounds very
religious it's all about religious
meaning but he
incredibly good at like getting across
the starkness of you know solidarity era
Poland and what what life was was like
and he framed these little moral
vignettes you know another director of
course if you want to get into like
Niall ism is Lars von Trier he's kind of
an acquired taste
so I think that that could be that could
be useful but I I don't usually think so
much about meaninglessness when I'm
showing a movie for philosophical themes
I'm usually like having my students
watch it so that we can then talk about
what the the other themes are right like
you know maybe you know another another
good movie that I've shown my class is
is eat drink man-woman which is about
family and how to deal with conflict and
it's got all this gorgeous food in it as
well and it's about you know vitality
and life and that sort of thing but
that's not really about meaninglessness
except for you know maybe characters
that have to figure out meaning in in a
new life so all right let's see Fock
totem what's my opinion of Dietrich
Bonhoeffer especially his ideas on duty
action and falling Christ I haven't read
Bonhoeffer since I was in graduate
school so I don't really have much to
say about about him unfortunately oh you
know scrolling down looks like some
people have some good suggestions here
about about different movies from No
Country for Old Men yeah that's that's a
really good one I'd say yeah Linden
mentions the Decalogue solemn spoke very
meaningful about meaninglessness okay
yeah that's good too hmm I don't
yeah I don't know that might be
something good to talk about it another
one another thing down the line when I
have more it's time to research movies
and think about it all right so let's
scroll back up and see what we've got
here
so journal is o slam RN wants to know
how well I read German I'm fine I just
don't speak it very well because I don't
have any occasion to do so Kostas how do
you present a novel idea to someone else
mm-hmm novel to them you mean because
because I don't I don't have an awful
lot of novel ideas myself I'm usually
cobbling together ideas from other
people but how do you present an idea
that somebody else has not been exposed
to it really depends on that person I
mean if you're dealing with somebody
who's very hostile to new ideas you
might need to candy-coat it and
introduce it to them in very small doses
there's all there's other people who are
like at the other extreme where they if
it's a new idea they want to hear about
it they they can't get enough of new
ideas and maybe then you'd you'd like
pump the brakes a little bit right so I
don't know there's it really I think it
really depends on the person stig
written do you think Camus was right
about meaning and the absurd I I don't
think that the world has the complete
lack of just complete lack of connection
to our desires and rationality that he
portrays it as having in myths of
Sisyphus and remember the absurd for him
is a divorce between the human being and
the world it's a third it's a triadic
relationship I do think that the world
does not have an you know like automatic
clear meaning to it I think human beings
often talk as if it does and it's up to
us I I'm more like say Gabrielle Marcel
or Simone de Beauvoir she talks about
the world being ambiguous
and Gabrielle Marcel talks about mystery
which means that we have to do a good
bit of work to call out the meaning
that's there in the world I'm not a good
bit of it also depends on the
development that we ourselves engage in
so alright Nathan asked I was wondering
what nature's ideas on free will and
determinism are yeah that's a good
question because there's a lot of people
who make way too much of the eternal
recurrence of the same which Nietzsche
doesn't say is the case that that would
be like complete determinism right he
presents it as kind of a hypothesis and
I don't really think that it's as
essential to his thought as say will to
power is or you know the clash between
different kinds of morality or you know
things along those lines I think that
Nietzsche is is he's willing to say that
many things do operate deterministically
but there is this capacity for you know
new things to arrive on the scene now
how do they arrive on the scene it's not
pure randomness we can like formulates
projects and ways of doing things for
ourselves and thereby exercise some
degree of freedom but there's nothing
like free will in the sense of like oh I
can like snap my fingers and do things
completely differently be not determined
by anything else
prior to to where I am but there's very
few philosophers who believe in free
will in that that respect that tends to
be more of a caricature of free will
than anything else so all right linden
asks what do you think of the idea
science does not have any one method or
the story of how science came about
diverges wide wide widely from the
romanticized version well science you
know with the sort of capital s meaning
all of the sciences does does not have
any one single method I know there's the
scientific method as people you know
teach it to us in in elementary and
middle and high school and sometimes in
college classes but observe scientists
actually at work and you see that that's
not how it works most of the time it's
not this you know rigid process that
they're supposed to be going through and
and we have all sorts of you know
problems with seeming seemingly rigorous
research that that has to be called into
question and there is something to you
know the notion that you know that is
Kuhn put forward back in what the
sixties late 60s or early 70s in this
notion of paradigms or frameworks there
there is something to that and then you
know we also want to think about science
is sort of like this this theoretical
academic project but then science is
like totally beholdin to the use of
technology which which is much more
practical and how does how does that
intervene and what role does that play
so I think that that's important now the
story of how science came about diverges
widely from the romanticized version is
the romanticized version the one the
sort of standard story that we get about
you you know you do some observations
and formulate a hypothesis then do some
experiments and then you know eventually
it gets replicated and and is that the
romanticized version because if it is I
mean all you have to do is actually like
hang out with scientists for a while and
you find out knots way more messy and
complicated than that
and way more political at any point in
time to I mean to shift gears a little
bit one of the things that Aristotle
gets right in the neck of McKay and
ethics is saying that political science
hey pal ATK that or you could call it
social science if you want is indeed the
architectonic one because it decides
what gets studied in the community right
so nowadays we would talk about like who
gets funded for what sort of research
and
towards what ends and with what sort of
measures in mind Aristotle was was
seeing that that was the case typically
a long time ago so Paul asks on the
reading of Marcus Aurelius would you
give it credit where credit is helpful
in the world yeah there's a lot of
people have been very very much helped
by reading Marcus Aurelius I think he's
he's quite quite interesting he's not
you know you know I would say if you
want more rigorous stoic stuff
definitely Seneca and Epictetus are
important and Marcus Aurelius you know
is drawing on Epictetus quite a lot so I
think that you know that that's good too
but I like Marcus Aurelius and we've
been going through the meditations in
our local stoic meetup book by book by
book you know one one book a month so
you know I think it's it's quite good he
you know he's not he's writing to
himself the book is actually called too
to himself so you can't take it as like
him teaching in an authoritative way or
anything like that but it's I I enjoy it
and I'll say too I enjoy it much more as
a later adult than I did in my teens and
20s when I when I tried to make sense of
it all right upon the face of the abyss
a thousand percent I find generally very
important for myself reflecting on my
days a lot of people yeah are very into
journaling I don't do it that much
myself but I'm usually have sort of an
interior discourse going on a lot of
time anyway so you know the thrill asks
do you sub vocalize when you read does
that mean like talking to yourself and
kind of a low voice no I don't usually
the only time I do something like that
is when people around me are being noisy
and I'm trying to like concentrate on
what I'm reading and then I might do
something like that
Paul hop what's your take on Peter
singers philosophy singers a consistent
utilitarian
I I am willing to accept some insights
from utilitarians but I'm actually a
virtue ethicist so I think that he's
actually off on some things but I think
there's some things that he says that
her that are quite good and and useful
and I enjoy teaching him in my classes
so you know but again I enjoy teaching
Khan too and I disagree with that on a
lot of stuff
let's see here
Jin stampede I saw another user asking
about Arab states and quoting Ollie's is
philosophy just where I guess jerking
off why doesn't Western academia study
African or Arab philosophy
well they do I mean I actually taught
classes on Africana philosophy like when
I was down at Fayetteville State
University and you know here in in
Milwaukee we actually have at Marquette
University the Aquinas and the Arabs
project and it's one of the places where
graduate students are studying Arabic
and talking about you know all the
different all's you know al farabi al
can be al ghazali and and and people are
getting you know quite excited about it
so there are people doing it I think
sometimes it could be due to a kind of
racism or you know dismissive attitude
towards anything that's not you know
within the Western Canon but I think a
lot of the time it's not it's not
anything quite so nefarious is that I
think it's just most places the amount
of philosophy they're studying is this
small and that's all they know and
that's all they were exposed to so they
don't know that there's much stuff
outside of there and that's I think
that's really what it is Linden has an
interesting question here about fitness
stuff what exercises do you love or hate
I love burpees and deadlifts most people
seem to hate them I'm not sure what a
Burpee is I just used machines I mean I
used to use free weights a lot in the
past but I'm content to do that I hate
curls I there's something I don't like
arm curls and I don't like
curls they're always painful I don't
like the the machine where you get on it
and you you twist from side to side with
your abs I just find that one tedious
what do you I like and I also don't like
the leg press but that's because I've
got some pretty damaged knees I'm
missing two ligaments in one knee and
the other knees had to compensate for
that for so long that it's kind of hard
on my knees and I'm always like worried
even though I use braces that
something's gonna get screwed up but I'd
do it anyway what are the exercises I
really like I like rowing I like I like
you know flies
I like tricep stuff I enjoy that and I
like some of the other legs stuff you
know Anna and I like that I like the
crunches I like doing the sit-up thing
where you've got you're holding the
thing and you go down and all that and
you know and I actually you know I do
cardio as well I really like the rowing
machine you probably stay that out I'm
at all day
I'm not sure what it is about rowing
that I like but I do enjoy it quite a
bit and I didn't at first like it but
now I've actually come to like the
elliptical so you know that's good it's
good if you like some things all right
here's a question from Giorgio is
rational philosophy moral Aristotle
founder of logic in his own ethics
justified slavery and advocated a
ministry of women how can rational
thinkers be so irrational in their views
well you're a subtle justified slavery
in a way but you do actually want to
read politics book one and see how
limited that justification was he said
that most enslavement of Greeks is
actually against nature and is just by
convention you know he had a different
attitude towards barbarians but I think
if he was brought up to the present he'd
change his mind about that I I don't
know about a Ministry of women is that
coming from the politics I mean he said
some bonehead
things about women but again if you're
if he had better experiences to draw
upon and not the Athenian society that
he was living in at the time he probably
would you know make more sense I think
it's important to keep in mind that
rationality is never like an on/off
switch it's always a continuum and it's
something that also does develop over
time as well and it's also important
when we're thinking about authors like
Aristotle we have to be very
scrupulously fair to what he does in
fact say and not you know engage in sort
of wild stuff about justifying slavery
we got to be we've got to be clear about
what he's actually justifying
and I guess you could say founded his
own logic he founded what he thought
what to be logic you know or more
properly a tool to organ on all right
but how can an irrational thinkers be so
irrational in their views I mean they're
human right and so you you I mean you
have a choice you can be very sort of
puritanical about that oh my gosh they
made any mistakes we have to dismiss
them or you can say well you know I like
this part here this part over here I
think is problematic can we use
resources from within Aristotle to
criticize Aristotle to to you know sort
of make it make it work out better we
can say and we can say similar stuff
about Plato or the Stoics or early
Christian thinkers we can go all the way
up to the present and we can find that I
doubt anybody is totally free of you
know grounds for critique or
contradiction the question is how
damaging is it to their projects so all
right let's see here a whit's caps rep
do I think studying might help someone
inclined on having negative thoughts it
depends on the philosophy that they're
studying I mean studying contemporary
analytic philosophy or just you know the
latest continental stuff probably not
going to be that helpful
studying philosophies conceived of as a
way of life you know like like
Aristotelian ism or stoicism or
Epicureanism you know early Christian
thought or stuff like that before it
kind of lapsed into scholasticism even
even some scholastics could be useful
for that probably yeah could could help
you but it's not not just by itself I've
brought this up in many conversations
you're really really good at an article
by I think it's Leslie Cosman on being
properly affected which is in an
Aristotle yeah here it is essays on
Aristotle's ethics which was edited by
my Rorty Emily Rory not not of course
you know the deconstructionist or
pragmatist Rorty and there's a really
great discussion in there ya know Lesley
Kozma this is the name being properly
affected virtues and feelings and
Aristotle's ethics and there was a line
in here that I underlined I think about
20 years ago and I think it's really
quite good and it was you know it's
going through this nice exegesis of
Aristotle and talks about this
developmental account and then here I'm
going to read this why should we not be
prepared to say that a person of
steadfast and cultivated virtue who
exhibits appropriate feelings and
circumstances which he understands
correctly and in which those are
precisely the feelings he would want to
exhibit taking into account the entire
fabric of his desires goals plans and
hopes for himself why should we not be
prepared to say that such a person has
chosen those feelings nowhere I believed
as Aristotle say this what we would like
but do not find is an extension of the
theory of deliberation and practical
reasoning to account for the ways in
which virtuous persons might be said to
have the proper feelings which they have
by prior races by deliberate choice and
then the art
goes on a little bit more and says in a
sense the theories behind certain
religious traditions psychoanalysis and
disciplines that promise self
transformation and self mastery might be
thought to represent attempts at such an
account and then there's this you know
sort of suggestion there that you know
if we were really good Aristotelian say
maybe what we would need to do is
supplement we don't we don't just use
Aristotle by Aristotle we supplement
Aristotle with what we can learn from
psychotherapeutic you know techniques
and spiritual direction and this and
this and that's in fact what
contemporary wrists Italians do Alastair
MacIntyre being a great example of
somebody who does that so could
philosophy studied in that way help you
out I think it probably could help you
out quite a bit
alright David the Dower dr. Saylor how
would you categorize yourself
philosophically as an eclectic that is
and there's two kinds of eclectic really
there's the smorgasbord eclectic who's
just like a little bit of this a little
bit of this and then there's the
eclectic sir like oh man there's a lot
of great stuff here I don't want to just
be committed to this one thing like as
if I'm committing to an orthodoxy I want
to take what's best in all of that and
synthesize it and that's very difficult
to do yeah another way another word for
that is pluralism and you can think
about that as like you know I kind of
like what what uh William James does in
advocates in his work as well so you
know that that's good all right let's
scroll up a little bit I I won't be able
to get to everybody by the way but I see
that there's a lot of side conversations
going on and which is which is nice and
scrolling down I'm not seeing too many
people being jerky to each other so all
right John Reeves Sam Harris the saint
anselm of today well you know knowing
and some pretty well
I would say that's that's a surprising
way to talk about Sam Harris to me but I
don't know maybe you have something else
in mind there
Anthony Fikri thoughts on alvin
plantinga's paper advice to Christian
philosophers it's not bad had planting a
read more widely in Christian philosophy
it would have been way better and that's
that's one of the problems with with
planting his work is that he just he's
kind of an interesting guy
I would actually seen him speak before
but he reinvents some wheels that don't
need to be reinvented and the advice
that he's giving is it suffers because
of that so it actually spurred an
interesting discussion that involved a
couple other contemporary thinkers like
Eleanor Stumpf at the time too there's
there's a whole literature out there on
it factotum what is your opinion on VAR
recognize to which degree can we
separate a work of art from its creator
especially if the work expresses the be
the feeling of the artist I don't I
don't think there's any easy answer to
that how you know it really depends on
the genre of the work and what they're
what they're doing is that the guy who
was the black metal fellow who was like
burning churches and I think he killed
somebody or something like that let me
actually look it up here okay yeah
convicted of murder and arson okay well
I mean I don't know much about the black
metal community in general cuz it's not
my it's not my bag you know I like I
like venom and that's really about it
and I like venom not because they're
black metal but because of you know the
the stuff that they do so you know I
don't really have too many feelings on
him let's see here
bozhe dar I think I may be pronouncing
it correctly
you know the Z with the reverse
circumflex any thoughts on Nick land and
Alan Watts I'm not big on either one I
don't I haven't read Nick lands fame
Newman ah I've you know always said if
people want me to read that book anybody
can feel free to send me a hard copy of
it and I will read it and review it but
I'm not going out of my way given how
much time I've got two voted two other
things to read land
and Alan Watts you know he had his time
I'm not myself drawn to to mysticism or
you know sort of broad generalizations
about Western rationality versus the
Eastern approach or stuff like that I
like to like be you know I like to say
well which which Eastern approach are
you talking about and you know some are
more rationalistic and some are less so
and and so I you know whatts is he's
he's interesting he's sorta like and
again somebody people ask me about
Thomas Merton as well and just I'm I'm
not into that that sort of thing I read
Watts quite a bit when I was a teenager
and in my early 20s and and I never I
never really bought in I have to say so
alright
stoic code says newly single needs some
advice on courtship well that's that's a
good thing for Valentine's Day right
well I mean I I think that one thing
that's important in terms of finding a
potential you know mate or life partner
or even just somebody who you're gonna
be enjoying time with for the present or
something like that is you know you need
to be attentive to them and be
respectful and you know work with a kind
of reciprocity don't don't treat them in
ways that you wouldn't want to be
treated yourself but you also you know
that doesn't mean that you have to like
put up with anybody doing anything
whatsoever
it's important to be able to lay down
limits and boundaries and say listen I
I'm okay with this and this I really
like but this I that you're doing over
here I don't like this and you know
figure out for yourself what's a
deal-breaker and what's what's not and
the other thing I would say too is you
know when when you have like a
relationship break up people always say
oh there's plenty of fish in the ocean
and that's usually like the one bit of
good advice that they give you because
they always look let's go drinking or
you know stuff like that they're really
are you know they're there's so many
people that you could you could meet and
you know there's always like a learning
curve and and all that but you know you
you don't have to expect that like the
first person that you date that it's
automatically gonna work out and then if
it doesn't work out and like maybe they
don't call you back or if the date
doesn't go wow that that's somehow like
your failure it may just be that you
just weren't you weren't on the same
wavelength and compatible so you know
don't don't let that sort of thing get
you to down I would say oh so wait what
am I saying wisdom is my first love well
okay well that's that's good let's see
I'm gonna scroll down past them side
conversation canal says what do I think
of benedito Croce Giovanni genteel a and
Italian idealism well I think I can't
really say much about it because it's
been a very long time since I read Croce
and I don't I don't know if I've even
read Gentilly so I'm not I'm not really
qualified to say very much about it
all right um let's see
Oh Volpe some culture thoughts on No
Country for Old Men I was a little
disappointed with the movie because it
had been talked up so much and I did
have some you know stars in it who I
but I I wasn't all that happy with with
the the resolution of it I thought it
was you know well done but it just it
wasn't it didn't measure up to the hype
so to speak for for me but I think a lot
of people really really enjoy it so
Hakeem koloth tov what are your views
about Marxism that's almost like you
know the what it would what about you
know the medievals or what about Islam
it depends on what we're talking about
Marxism has turned into its own
tradition in the MacIntyre Ian sense
MacIntyre by the way was a Marxist for a
long time so I think that there's
there's some insights to it that are
valid and good I think that it's been
used and abused and in many ways that
are particularly good I do you know
resist the trying to blend Marxism into
things that it's not like claiming that
it's you know the you know when somebody
uses the term called for Marxism I just
basically turn and turn them off in my
brain because there's not much that
that's gonna come out of their mouth
that's any good or when somebody equates
Marxism with post-modernism you know you
look at you say well if that's the case
then you know what was say Terry
Eagleton doing as a Marxist complaining
about post-modernism you know or Samuel
Harrington in his politics at God's
funeral or so they're distinct
traditions you know but but I think
carrying out class analyses and again
that's not really restricted to Marxism
Marx just happened to be a particularly
successful sociologist and a philosopher
and economist in that way but you can
carry out class analysis and it's it's
you know it's quite valid the notion
that that economic process sees could
generate ideologies I kind of you know I
think that's that's quite true
so does Nietzsche he thinks that's true
as well so yeah all right vault bass
asks have you seen 1408 philosophical
horror film no I haven't that would be
interesting
Phillip Schofield am i single I am NOT I
have been married now since 2011 so what
is that nine years very happily married
unfortunate enough to have you know met
the person who really is my soul mate
nice thing to be able to say on
Valentine's Day doesn't mean the things
are ever like you know in life
automatically easier that like you know
every morning we wake up to wonderful
violin music and you know hearts as if
it's an Instagram filter like that right
but I do have somebody who's really it
was really great across the spectrum you
know beautiful brilliant hard-working
you know committed all those sorts of
things all right program what
philosophical questions do you think
about the most often I would say you
know a lot of what I'm doing is really
concerned with understanding the human
being so you could say I work a lot in
the Philosopher's human nature and I'm
thinking about like how does human
beings use the limited rationality and
and limited freedom that we have to
expand on that and make it a bit better
but I'm also thinking about pedagogical
philosophical questions like okay I've
got Aristotle here how do I get this
stuff across to undergraduates who have
you know never heard anything about this
guy and may not be all that interested
in it you know service classes a lot of
people look down on teaching intro
classes those are the hardest classes to
teach anybody can teach graduate
students yeah that's that's that's
simple you just they're self-motivated
they've already read a lot of the
literature they know the jargon you just
kind of point them at stuff and and you
don't even have to teach a class if
you're doing a grad
now you just say okay week one you're
presenting week one year presenting what
you're presenting that's the easiest
thing in the world teaching
undergraduates who are not philosophy
majors to appreciate what's going on in
philosophy that is stuff and so I I
devote a lot of thought to how to do
that let's see here Godfrey Keller is a
former Catholic I would like to ask you
the following why do you believe in God
and what makes Catholicism more accurate
than any other versions of Christianity
I don't actually think a thought ISM is
more accurate in any sort of sense but
I'm I can't see you know not being in
any of the churches that trace
themselves back effectively to the
Apostles because I know plenty of I know
plenty of church history and I have a
strong appreciation for the you know
Christian intellectual traditions going
all the way back I mean you see right
here next to me the church fathers right
and you know I why do I believe in God
there's no one single like thing that
and I think this is the case room for
most people there's no one single thing
that's like the linchpin you know it's
not like I read the ontological argument
one day and it's like holy crap there it
is now everything else falls into place
and I've said this many times but I'll
say I think it's worth saying again
myself I've always found that belief in
God and and all of that doesn't like
solve problems for it just makes things
way more complicated and adds to your
list of stuff you gotta do and think
about and I like the thinkers for whom
God being in the picture didn't make
things simple so like Kierkegaard for
example right Kierkegaard is well he
takes a leap of faith
well sure takes a long time to get
around to it doesn't it and after he
does it he's still not saying everything
has been solved
he writes book after book after book
after book you know
or Pascal or you know Augustine or Ansem
you know you might say well handsome he
was a monk he chose to be a monk right
and then he got stuck being Abbot and he
got stuck being Bishop and he's writing
in the pro slogan and he's saying I
can't find God I I you know and yet I
can't escape God and there's all this
paradoxical stuff about God how can he
be this and this at the same time those
are the those are the things that are
really interesting to probe and I I'm
attracted to the thinkers for whom
that's that's more of a problem that you
know when the atheist apologist comes to
them and they're like yes but what about
this they're like that is a real problem
yeah let's let's sit here and think
about that a bit you know the problem of
evil real serious issue I'm not gonna
try to sweep it under the rug or
anything so those are the things that
I've I've found interesting all right
I'm gonna have to go wow we're already
at an hour and five minutes I'm gonna
have to go pretty soon because it's
gonna be time for us to have our dinner
and stuff like that so I'm just gonna
grab a few questions at random and and
take them oh well here's a question from
land of lions avicennia my herd of zero
Jakob and Africa and Ethiopian
philosopher had similar views to Rene
Descartes and would it be possible to
make video on him I certainly have heard
of him I've read glosses on him I
haven't read him yet but I find what I
would have read about him quite
intriguing and yeah I could make videos
on him once I've actually read and
digested his stuff and that probably
wouldn't happen any time this semester
cuz I'm you know teaching and making
videos on for my classes on things that
I need done but he does sound quite
interesting so you know that's a
possibility Pro home do you do I also
listen to Rage Against the Machine
I don't but we're going to be seeing
them in concert here at Alpine Valley
and I think in the summer because my my
likes them quite a lot and so you know
I'm open to listening to them have I
studied mob Raj since I seemed interest
myself in the Christian philosophy of
the French language I have but it's been
a very long time since I read mob rush
that was back in graduate school as well
so yeah let's see what a lot of back and
forth things here oh here's a good one
from stoic Oh tis loving yourself first
vain or should one put their partner
first why make it that binary why not
try to do both why not love yourself and
you know respect yourself enough to
sometimes insist on like saying what you
need and and in enforcing boundaries and
stuff like that and love the other
person and try to work out a balance
between the two I think that's probably
the healthiest way and try to find
somebody else who can have a similar
[Music]
similar take and respect that take you
know I mean if you can find it that
would be kind of kind of nice I mean I
realize I'm setting the bar kind of high
so here's a good one to go out on with
Nick and so then I'll I'll I'll have to
beg off after this are heidegger's
lectures on others other philosophers
Aristotle or contour needs are worth
exploring if so are there any particular
you would recommend yeah Heidegger's
lectures on other people are often quite
good I'm I wouldn't recommend the Hegel
one because it's very short and he only
goes up to the self consciousness
section I mean what's what's there is
pretty good but you're you're gonna be
disappointed in it because you're like
what the hell you know the phenomenology
he only did this much of it right but
how do you have some really great
lectures on Aristotle he's I mean you're
getting Heidegger on air
but there's a lot of good insights there
he's got a lot of good stuff on play-doh
his Nietzsche lectures I think are you
know quite superb and there's a lot of
them there that there's four volumes of
Nietzsche lectures and then he's you
know he's got a smattering of other
stuff as well and we're fortunate in
that a lot of it's been translated at
this point so it I would say it's it's
worth it's worth checking out you you
know it's sort of like with other main
figures like when you read kochava and
Hegel you're really getting a lot of
codes you have and and not as much Hegel
same thing with Heidegger on our stuff
it's not a very close it is a close
reading of the text but it's a heidi
garyun close reading of the text but you
can say the same thing about other other
you know people who do history of
philosophy stuff like Duluth for example
right to lose his book on live dances
the fold is great but it's to lose on
line myth so you know and and so I think
that's a good good fitting end to all of
this
couldn't get to everybody's questions
but I never do so hope all of you have a
great evening or morning or whatever it
is where you happen to be I know some of
you are over in Europe and so it's got
to be middle of the night now for you so
thanks for joining in and you know I'll
do more of these now that I've got a
good mic and my schedule is more or less
regular and probably do that do more of
these on Fridays quite frankly because
that's one of the days that I usually
have a little bit of extra time so or I
have a great Valentine's Day or the day
after if you're already there and I'll
see you at the next event